- - Est-ce que le déploiement
dudu réseau 5G pourrait avoir
dedes conséquences néfastes
susur l'aviation civile? C'est e
quque croient les dirigeants d'e
didizaine de grandes compagnies
aéaériennes qui mettent en garde
leles autorités que ce qu'ils
ququalifient de potentielle "cre
cacatastrophique" si cette
tetechnologie est installée
àà proximité des aéroports.
IlIls ont demandé la suspension
imimmédiate de ce déploiement.
DeDeux géants de la téléphonie
momobile ont consenti de retardr
cece déploiement aujourd'hui.
OnOn tente de comprendre pourqui
avavec Mehran Ebrahimi, professr
auau département management
etet technologie de l'UQAM
etet Jean Lapointete, pilote à a
reretraite. Bonsoir à vous deux.
D D'abord, expliquez-nous
ququels risques posent le
dédéploiement de la 5G sur
lele monde de l'aviation?
- - En fait le problème c'est
ququ'avec 5G on va modifier la
frfréquence et ça pourrait créer
dede l'interférence avec ce qu'n
apappelle un appareil qui mesure
l'l'attitude de l'avion et ça pe
unun problème dans la mesure oùe
pipilote a besoin de cet altimèe
lala pour pouvoir préciser leur
atatterrissage surtout quand la
tetempérature est mauvaise donca
pepeut envoyer des informations
ererronées au pilote et ça peut
cacauser un problème sérieux.
- - De saboter des dirigeants de
cocompagnies aériennes, même les
didirigeants des émirats, dit
ququ'il n'y récompensait des
ininitiales déploiements de la .
- - il y a un doute donc c'est n
ququand on en parle avant de les
memettre en fonction.
CÇa n'a fait trois pas les phass
dede vol tel que le décalage oue
vovol de croisière ou un
atatterrissage par beau temps
c'c'est vraiment accueillera des
atterrissages qui sont faits
dadans des aéroports où il y a
sosouvent de la la brume, comme
dadans San Francisco, il faut
sasavoir qu'à ce moment-là,
popourquoi on crée ainsi que sia
frfréquence aux États-Unis du
réréseau 5G se rapproche de la
frfréquence utilisée par
l'l'appareil radio altimètre qui
s's'accroupit le lors d'un
atatterrissage par pilote
auautomatique on a des doutes à
sasavoir s'il était et du systèe
lolors d'un atterrissage aussi
dedemandant pourrait jouer conte
lala sécurité aérienne?
- - Et cet altimètre vous en avt
ababsolument besoin ça
acactuellement ou l'avion se
trtrouve par rapport aux termes?
- - C'est pas un altimètre
babarométrique comme on utilise
dadans un bol normal si un, ça
enenvoie des fréquence vers le l
etet s'est réfléchi par le hautt
l'l'avion c'est en tout temps à
ququelle attitude il est, et c't
efeffectivement utilisé pour
pepermettre au pilote automatiqe
d'd'atterrir l'avion dans des
coconditions de visibilité toutà
fafait réduite.
- - Et comment cela qu'on se
reretrouve dans cette crise la à
lala veille de voir des téléphoe
momobile déployait leurs 5G et e
çaça se retrouve à la Maison-
BlBlanche et que les ministre ds
TrTransports mail prend la part
dedes compagnies aériennes?
- - Ça fait un moment ça fait
prpresque deux ans que la a quen
esest sur la table et on pensait
ququ'en vendant les fréquences à
dedes compagnies de télécom ça
alallait faire parti des
cocontraintes, il faut croire qe
çaça été très fort et que le
sesecteur de l'aviation avait un
auautre c chat à fouetter durant
leles deux dernières années pose
onon n'a pas vraiment mis ça à
l'l'avant-plan mais il faut dire
auaussi que dans le cas des... s
onont acheté pour 40 milliards e
dodollars donc ça question de gs
sosous et envoie mes encaisse la
coconfrontation de deux
phphilosophies des compagnies de
tétéléphone sont à la recherchee
prprofit ce qui est normal et ça
heheurte une autre culture des
cocompagnies aériennes qui veuet
auaussi des profits mais surtout
unune sécurité.
EnEn aviation ne peueut jamais
nénégliger la sécurité et c'estn
élélément important qui fait
ququ'aujourd'hui on a vu que les
rerestrictions que le gouvernemt
amaméricain a donné ça ne
sasatisfait pas le secteur où le
pépérimètre doit être affaibli
c'c'est très peu par rapport aux
auautres aéroports dont tous
aiaisément on pensait que les
rrèglements allaient être plus
trtraités ça n'a pas été le cas.
- - Je crois comprendre que aux
EÉtats-Unis on a moins de
réréglementation et que les taux
popouvant être plus proche des
aéaéroports qu'en Europe est-ce
quque je me trompe?
- - Oui la fréquence utilisée ax
EÉtats-Unis semble se rapprocher
dede la fréquence des radio
alaltimètre qu'en Europe pouour
cecette puissance est inquiétane
mamais maintenant plusieurs
enendroit les gouvernements come
enen France demande que des
anantennes soient au moins à 3,2
kmkm d'une piste d'atterrissage
ututilisé pour les atterrissageà
mamauvais temps donc il faudra
vovoir ce que transport Canada
dédécidera ici pour nous, mais e
pepense que la sécurité devra
totoujours être mise de l'avant.
- - En France ou en Europe
auaujourd'hui quand un pilote
ararrive dans cette espèce de ze
cocouverte par l'interdiction du
5G5G sont environ 85 secondes de
vovol ou le pilote peut être das
unune zone où le 5G est très
fafaible ou absent et aux États-
UnUnis c'est seulement 20
sesecondes.
EnEn France on a demandé à ce qe
leles centaines soient inclinées
vevers le sol pour que ça fasse
momoins d'angle dans leur
ininterférence donc ce sont des
éléléments qui viennent rajouter
etet la fréquence est moins fore
dodonc c'est plus sécuritaire.
- - Jean Lapointe, supposons que
dedemain vous êtes aux commandes
d'd'un avion et que la 5G était
dédéployée bourguignonne auriez
papas aimé beaucoup prendre ce
ririsque là?
- - Non et ce qu'on peut voir ce
ququi est des sociétés aériennes
vovont empêcher le pilote et je
pepense que les propriétaires de
grgrandes compagnies télécom ont
cocompris que plusieurs des
papassagers sont des utilisateus
dedes avions donc de ce côté
popolitique ça va se régler et i
vava payer pour les ajustementsà
vevenir on va voir si le bras de
fefer économique et la sécurité
sesera mise de l'avant mais j'ai
bobon espoir que dans les mois i
viviennent tout va se régler
- - c'était passionnant merci